تطور اخر اقتحم من مستوطنون المسجد الاقصى
صباح اليوم بحمايه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بمناسبه عيد الانوار اليهوديه
وبست وسائل الاعلام فلسطينيه مشاهد تظهر
جانبا من بدء عمليات الاقتحام ومضايقه
قوات الاحتلال للمرابطات في الاقصى
وكانت حركه حماس دعت الى شد الرحال وتكثيف
الرباط في الساحات الوزير افضل لصدق
اقتحامات المستوطنين بدءا من اليوم الاحد
في عيد الانوار او حكونا
وقالت حماس في بيان ان الاقتحامات الواسعه
التي تخطط لها جماعات الصهيونيه تصعيد
خطير واستفزاز لمشاعر الشعب الفلسطيني
وعامه المسلمين وحملت حركته حماس حكومه
الاحتلال المسؤوليه الكامله عن تداعيات
الاقتحامات والاستفزازات المصاحبه لها كما
طلبت الحركه الدول العربيه والاسلاميه
بتحرك العاجل لحمايه المسجد الاقصى من خطر
التهويد